hi everyone so as he said then Paul
again so I work at Bloomberg I'm a
software engineer there I also am a
pretty frequent contributor to open
source so today we're talking to you
about contributing an open source
usually when I interact with people and
they hear that I do a lot of open source
I maintain libraries like date you tale
and set up tools and I've contributed to
a number of projects I often hear oh you
know I'd like to contribute to open
source more but or I'd like to
contribute at all but it's just too hard
you know I don't have the patience to
deal with like people who are always
like asking for all these changes or
they you know I feels like screaming the
Boyd I'm just opening issues and pull
requests and no one ever responds to
them and you know I'm not going to
pretend like that doesn't happen
probably part of the reason why I don't
find contributing to open source
terribly difficult is because I have a
more and easier a less strenuous
definition of what is too difficult to
actually accomplish what I have found
that there are a couple things where if
you sort of know the right ways to do
things if you understand if you
understand what everyone's mindset is
and also if you have just try and keep
open good lines of communication you can
make things a little easier at least so
why do people contribute to open source
one of the reasons is that you have some
problem and you need to solve it and you
don't want to maintain a fork of the of
the upstream library or maybe it's you
know like the guy shoveling his his snow
here the snow from his path here right
like if when he fixes his problem which
is I can't get to my car you can fix it
for everybody by shoveling the sidewalk
instead of you know just picking up the
snow and putting it behind and like as
you go so that no one else can make use
of that another reason to take
contribute to open source is for the
community right maybe you like
interacting with open-source maintainer
or maybe you like contributing to some
greater
thing or maybe you feel like they've
done a lot for you you know they
provided libraries that you use and you
want to give back in some sense that's
how I initially got involved and also
you know it's it's like it feels kind of
cool to be like hey I like built this
thing which is like used by Nobel Prize
winners or whatever or or any of these
kind of hugely used projects you know
it's kind of nice to know that you've
done even some small part of it so oh
but I should note that these types of
contribution are two very different
modes right the first one is very
goal-oriented it says I have some kind
of change that I want to see in this
project the second one says I would like
to help you so what are the changes that
you would like to see in the project now
I think that open-source needs both of
these types of contributions so I'm not
gonna say like one is better than the
other but you should note that they have
very different challenges the first one
has a challenge which is I need to
convince you to make this change the
second one is I need to find the things
that need to be changed and the things
that will be useful contributions so
just keep that in mind as you're as
you're making contributions that those
are the two challenges so what are the
types of contributions you can make the
first one the big exciting one is
features if you add a feature to
something it's very visible it increases
the abilities of the project you're like
oh I added this you know I made it so
matplotlib has radial plots now or
something right
but features are one of the hardest
things get merged into a an open-source
project and the reason is that they're
very complicated they're if they use a
lot of there's a lot of they take a lot
of time there's a lot of communication
that has to go on and generally speaking
you end up with some situation like this
kind of feature where someone sort of
half constructs it like bit like they
want to put in a door and they only get
through the stairs
or maybe it's something or as a
miscommunication it's like actually the
stairs are supposed to go in front of
the door in the front of the house and
you put it on the side of the house so
you know these kinds of things there's a
lot of like avenues where you can just
go just take a wrong turn and then eat
your thing never gets merged and it just
blocks easier to get in is bug fixes of
course it's a sort of definition problem
like what is the bug fix and what's a
feature what's what breaks
backwards-compatibility and what doesn't
but if some something in the library was
obviously intended to work a different
way and you can fix it without breaking
backwards compatibility that
contribution will likely get accepted if
you if it's well formed and so that's
probably easier to start with for your
first contribution but again you're
gonna need communication to make it
clear that you understand what the
maintainer think the bug is and that
that means you know and that you're
listening when the maintainer czar
trying to to to figure out whether or
not you're all on the same page and then
there's documentation fixes
documentation fixes are basically like
you just merge them before you even read
them like that's not actually true but a
lot of the concerns with bug fixes and
features and stuff are just not there
with documentation fixes in the sense
that there's no API compatibility issues
if something goes wrong you just like
fix it in the next merge it's not a
problem
and there's also there's also no chance
that changing the documentation is going
to break someone's existing code in prod
right like if some you're gonna hear it
if you make some bug fix that breaks a
bunch of stuff in prod because people
were relying on some behavior of your
library that you considered a bug if
it's documentation you'll hear about it
eventually the other reason why
documentation fixes are pretty easy to
get merged is because documentation is
pretty labor-intensive and it and so it
tends to decay faster than things where
you can have automated tests for it
which is which is all just to say that
documentation is easy to get merged not
because it's easy to do
because it's hard to do and another kind
of contribution that is often overlooked
when thinking about contributing open
source is issues so generally when
you're using some application or some
library or whatever and it has some
issue do you like stop everything and
find the correct repository and then
write a detailed error message that you
send to the maintainers you know
obviously you don't do that you just
work around it or just be like oh how
annoying and then you continue about
with your day but that's essentially the
only way that maintain is get feedback
about how their libraries or projects
are are breaking in the real world and
so anytime you see an issue you probably
have a hundred or a thousand users who
have the same issue but just kind of
ignored it but an important part of
writing issues is writing good issues
because a lot of times you you can make
an issue and and you say here's this
problem and then you walk away and
nothing ever happens with it and part of
the reason why that happens is because
it you need to make sure that like is
because essentially issues that don't
that don't have certain elements are a
lot harder to reproduce they're a lot
harder to understand and as a result
they're a lot harder to take action on
so here's an exemplary issue that I took
from the formatter black this person Ned
made this issue it has to do with type
annotation comments and you know they
start with the list of their versions
their operating system the version of
black they're using they checked if it
works on master and the version of
Python that they're using right all of
that is so that when the maintainer goes
through and tries to replicate your
issue and they can't maintain it they
don't have to come back and ask you like
okay what is your version of Python and
then they try it again right you put all
that up front so that they can replicate
your environment as a starting point
they also put the motivation one thing
that maintainer is going to be looking
for is that is this in scope and your if
you're not telling them about your use
case they're probably just going to say
well I've never I can't imagine a time
that I would
this so maybe this is just out of scope
so if you give a little background about
here's why I need this they will either
tell you you know this is kind of out of
scope here's the right thing to use or
they'll say huh I never thought of that
we'll do it we should emerge that then
it's followed up with a minimal
reproducing example right so this starts
with some code and then the outcome of
that code in case it doesn't reproduce
on my machine and I'm seeing something
different and then also the desired
outcome so what they've done is they
said here's some code it does this it
should do this these three things allow
you to pretty easily understand what the
bug is and you also notice that this is
called a minimal reproducing issue so
this is not linked to some to some
repository and then the guy says I run
this on my code and then look at line
753 and you'll see that there's a
problem in the third argument right it's
def F and three very three parameters
named a B and C like this is the
absolute bare minimum it's four lines or
five lines of Python that you can save
to add up to I run black on it and it
gives you the thing now making these
minimally reproducing issues is hard I
suggest reading up about them because
they are a skill it's worth its weight
in gold
though that doesn't really make sense
because ideas don't have weight so that
was a bad metaphor but I recommend
reading a mat Rockland's blog post on
this craft craft minimal blog reports
and also the elements of a good issue
are very similar to the elements of a
good stack overflow question so reading
the stack overflow help on how to create
a minimal complete verifiable example is
also very useful for this what that
sounds like a lot of work so I suggest
you don't do that work if you don't need
to so always start by searching for the
existing issues and for us because you
might find that someone has raised the
exact same issue and maybe they only got
halfway through the process and you can
find a more minimal reproducing issue or
you can you know sort of move the ball
down the field like another 10 meters so
you'll note that we all fall prey to
this so this is an example of an issue
that I raised on detail which had been
raised quite a long time ago
and the maintainer was like yeah this is
a real issue and we should fix it and
that maintainer was also me three years
ago so I should have taken my own advice
so now you've got your issue done and
you have and you're ready to make a pull
request like how do you get your pull
request accepted to start we should like
we have to take a little detour into
like maintainer psychology because when
when the maintainer is the one that
they're gonna have to push the merge
button and the first thing to note is
that the main thing is probably assuming
that you're going to go away
you're going to like give this
contribution and it's going to be like
welcomed and we're gonna say thank you
but then we're gonna have to deal with
that for the next several years so we're
gonna be looking at the pull request
from a holistic point of view like how
does this fit with the rest of the
library does this have backwards
compatibility issues is this something
that's going to be harder to fix if I'm
not totally right about it and also do I
understand it do I understand that this
is the right solution another critical
factor in maintainer psychology is that
maintain errs generally our time
strapped they're not usually people
whose full-time job is doing this they
just do it kind of on weekends or lunch
breaks or or after work or something so
they're gonna be looking for things that
they can do in like short bites like
thirty minutes at a time they can
understand it quickly and then they can
take action on it and then put it on a
to-do list and the longer it goes the
more likely it is to go on the long list
and they're never going to look at it so
what you want to do when you're crafting
your pull request is to make sure that
it's something that can be easily
verified which means that it has tests
usually sometimes it feels like when
your maintainer your whole job is asking
people for tests you say oh can we add
some tests this line is not covered like
we need to cover this other feature it's
not just me Jeff over there also asking
for tests and in matplotlib they're also
asking for tests you know this I have
like a joke this was supposed to go over
the edge of the slide but this screen is
more screen resolution so let's just
pretend I have like six more of these
issues but yeah test
critical if it comes in with tests I'm
immediately going to look at it much
more favorably because I can easily say
if I merge this and then I do something
that breaks it that breaks the thing
that you just fixed I will know about it
you also need to provide context so if I
were to give you this thing and say like
hey I mean if you're trying to review a
contribution you kind of need to know
what it's for it so I give you this
thing I say like hey how good is this at
at whatever it does right like what I
don't know yeah I found this by
searching for contraption right but now
if I tell you what this does what this
does is it takes the energy from a
falling weight and uses it to launch
ping-pong balls immediately several
elements fall into place there's a
weight right there
that's probably used to launch the
ping-pong balls what's this rod for oh
well it's the same diameter as the thing
with the weight this is probably
something with air in it here's a tube I
understand the entire machine
immediately from the context except for
this part which is some kind of yellow
square thing and that is the part of the
contribution that you want to review
you're gonna say what's this yellow
square thing for and then they're going
to say oh it's for measuring the angle
or whatever right and then you say great
merged you also want to do things in
manageable chunks you know one change at
a time again maintains are not going to
have like three hours to dig into your
problem so if you have some pull request
that's like 700 lines and it changes
five different features but is great if
you had done it in five different pull
requests like if you like totally
overhaul my library and fix all the bugs
that's awesome if you do it in one pull
request that's a ton of work all at one
time just to press the merge button so
you're gonna want to do things in
manageable bites and you also want to
consider the support burden things that
changed a public API add to the public
API those are things that you have to
support in an ongoing way as soon as it
gets merged if you decide that you don't
want it anymore you have to go through a
deprecation cycle so you're coming along
with your with your feature and you're
saying hey here's this free feature
isn't it great you know and you're
thinking that free is free as in beer
but
maintainer is thinking that it's free is
in puppy right and you know a funny
story I was searching on CC search for
the Creative Commons license images and
I searched for puppy and I was like oh
look at that cute little guy you know
what the name of this is this is red
wolf dot jpg so this guy's not gonna
grow up to be like a fun dog this is a
wolf okay so we're through the we're
through with the social aspects of
contributing to open source hopefully
this is not going to just bore everybody
but I find a surprising number of people
well not surprising because it is this
crazy weird and complicated thing that
most people don't understand but a large
number of people don't really understand
what's going on when they're making a
pull request so I thought I would just
go through and give you some
abstractions that I have found very
useful
so with git you have some repositories
say this is the canonical repository you
want to make a copy of it that's called
cloning it so you clone a local copy you
always work in a branch you don't work
on the master branch because that it's
way harder to sync things when you are
working directly in your master branch
so you make a branch these add your
commits and then you'll either push this
commits up or the other person will pull
them to that branch and then when
they're ready they'll take those changes
and they merge it and that creates this
little merge commit but github is
slightly different than get in the sense
that it has more permissioning issues
and it has a different slightly
different workflow but it's still based
on that same concept and I talked about
github not because we're at Microsoft
but because like you know some huge
number of open-source projects use it
but the concepts are similar for git lab
and bitbucket so on github you have some
canonical repository and because you
don't have permissions to push directly
to the to that repository you're going
to need to make a fork and what the fork
does is it makes a copy of that on
github server that you have permissions
on then you're going to take that and
you're going to clone your fork into
your local branch and you're also going
to want to connect it to the original
branch by adding it as a remote so
traditionally you're the your fork is
called origin and the the canonical
repositories felt up
dream and these are all linked together
these two are origin and upstream are
both on github server logos on your
computer so local is the one where you
can make changes so you make your branch
you should name it something reasonable
like fixed race condition if you're
fixing a race condition then you push it
to your origin because that's where you
have the ability to make changes and
then from there you make a pull request
to upstream which is saying upstream
please pull these changes in and merge
them upstream will merge them and then
you will pull from upstream not from
your origin to get these new changes in
and then you can delete your branch and
continue working that way so here's what
it looks like on github you have you
press the fork button it creates
something that's identical except that
it's in your name face instead of the
orgs you clone the repository in in your
terminal using this this little link
they give you you make your commits you
make a branch and you push it to the
origin and these slides are all online
if you go on my website Ansel bio you
can find the links to it so you don't
have to I know I'm going through this
pretty fast so when you then once you've
pushed it to the origin you can create
the pull request generally when you go
to the website it'll helpfully like be
like hey I know you probably want to do
this and that'll pop up it doesn't
always pop up it only pop something like
the first 10 minutes or hour or
something so if it's been a while and
you don't see that you just navigate to
your fork you go you change the branch
to be the one that you want to and then
you press this button that says pull
request that will open up this dialog
and then you just fill it out you give
it a descriptive you give it a
descriptive title you give it a
description I filled in the description
that says I'm this is a pull request to
add these slides to this repository so
this is actually these screenshots are
from the polar press that I used to add
these to make these slides so this is
probably not like the most clarity if it
wasn't for me because the maintainer
would be like wait what so once that's
done
you're gonna see this pop up at the end
of your at the end of your thing this is
continuous integration so generally open
source projects because again
maintainers are strapped for time we'll
set up continuous integration which is
something that we'll listen for changes
but listen for pull requests it'll pull
in those changes
it'll merge them and then it'll run all
your tests you set it up to run all the
tests on different platforms and all
that kind of stuff so you'll see these
little hooks this means it's waiting
when it comes when it when it's finished
you'll either get a checkmark that says
hey all the tests pass or you'll get
like a little X that says okay something
went wrong here so now I know something
went wrong look the no maintainer has
told me anything about what went wrong
it immediately tells me just from me
coming back and looking and then I can
dig in I go on Travis here and I see
this pull request failed on Python three
point three I click on the Python three
point three and I see it gives me a
whole log I find the error message it's
helpfully in red I find out that this is
something about in Python three point
three one of my dependencies stop
supporting Python three point three so
now it's failing
so then I make the changes I pinned that
version to three point three everything
is green again I go back into the into
my pull request everything is green and
now the maintainer is free to merge so
now I'm going to go through just quickly
one of these an interaction that I
thought was pretty good you know open
source and please forgive me github
designers and the people involved in
this I've I just like modified the Dom
of this in the inspector so that it
would look nicer on slides this so like
I changed some of the font sizes and
things like that so this person they
wanted to make a change they they said
oh here's the error that I'm happening
they gave their motivation all that
stuff and you'll notice they had three
commits one of them is add failing task
test so they added tests good they fix
the test and then they fix the example
in the documentation great those are all
the elements that we want to see and the
maintainer came in and he said hey I
would love to merge this last minute for
this change I'm about to release what
could you please add a team's log entry
this is the first place where this kind
of
right if you didn't come back to look
for this you would not know that they're
waiting on you to add a change log entry
and he said last minute right I would
like to merge us at the last minute so
that's kind of time-sensitive you if
you're if you're paying attention like
if you're watching your notifications
you'll you'll want to be you'll get
these sort of timely notifications so
they said that's awesome and they added
a change log entry just by pushing more
stuff to their branch and then they said
oh also like see how this is like a red
X as something is failing what's failing
and they mentioned it's something to do
with the coverage right so then the
maintainer says oh here maybe try doing
this you use this monkey patch to get it
and if that doesn't work just be like
you know what forget it we don't have to
cover this line it's fine and then they
they made the change they're like oh
that's great and they also said today I
learned about high test monkey monkey
much so by you know having this
interaction not only is this good for
the project it's good for this person
because they learn something about about
Python that they wouldn't have otherwise
know so then it was done but the Travis
was still failing so what they did was
they pushed another thing that says make
flaky happy so evidently this was some
living error but you'll notice the
maintainer did not say hey can you fix
this thing that is making flaky unhappy
because they're right they just looked
at the continuous integration saw what
was failing and then fix it and then
right it got merged
yeah it's kind of funny the good issue
on the other one was issue number 282 in
black
this is pull request number 282 in
others so there's something about like
282 that makes things good alright so
hopefully I've convinced you that you
should contribute to open source and
I've given you some tools to go and do
it so what what what's the next step
what's your action item right so let's
assume that you want to do the community
mode right you want to say I'm gonna get
back you want to pick a project so I
would say pick something that interests
you and then look at it and check for
indications of the activities
probably not gonna have a like it's not
impossible that inactive projects will
merge your stuff and make new releases
but it's probably not great for the
first time to try and sort of fight
against that because the probability of
getting stuff merged in a largely
inactive project it is much lower and
you want to check out the project
highest tests it's a total pain to make
changes in in projects that don't have
tests because not only does the
maintainer not have feedback I mean
they're probably used to that but you
don't have feedback as you're making
changes that you didn't break anything
else and then when you're like alright I
want to contribute to this read the
contributing got MD that's usually in
the in the the root directory of the of
the repository but if it's not sometimes
it seemed like that github but if you
click on pull request I'll get up there
like super helpful about this so like
hey there's these contributing
guidelines like why don't you if you
click on this button it'll bring you to
an umpire's contributing that MD so now
you've found a project you read they're
contributing MD now you want to find an
issue the best way to start is to click
on something is to look for a label
that's like good first issue or one
that's like Help Wanted a lot of times
what happens is that you have these
issues that got raised and the reason
that they haven't been fixed is they're
like it's just not clear how how how to
fix them or they're blocked on some
other project or they blocked on some
other thing that's happening so a lot of
maintainer x' who especially once we're
welcoming to new contributors will go
through and they'll label all the all
the issues that are likely to be
interesting they're likely to be easy to
fix you know from a new contributor
we're just going to ignore the phone
thing and then yeah so I'm just gonna
keep going here the if you found an
issue maybe that you do want to fix
maybe it's an issue that you then you
want to fix because it's like it's
actually affecting you you should read
yeah read the history of it and try and
gauge what needs to be done and it
doesn't hurt to sort of ask in the issue
like hey I would like to fix this is
there anything I should know is it a
problem and you'll notice that in this
issue which has a lot of comments which
is can be a bad sign if it's a pretty
old issue it probably means that there
was a lot of attention paid to it and
still no was able to fix it you know
they said is there anything I could do
and the maintainer was like yeah we did
all the easy stuff and now it's like
hard and we don't know how to fix the
rest of it so we left it open but hey
click on the good first issue that's
great and another thing I would mention
is you should stick around so you know
there's a lot of overhead you know fixed
costs that goes into making a
contribution you have to figure out how
their tasks work you have to clone the
repo fork the repo understand how the
project works enough to fix this one bug
so fixing one bug is like maybe pretty
hard right or moderately hard right
fixing two bugs it's probably much
easier than fixing you know then to then
fix fixing two bugs in the same repo is
probably much easier than fixing one bug
on two different repos
so this happened with me so this is
probably the second open-source pull
request I ever made it was on date you
tale I fixed some issue with checking
against none in a constructor and then
like the next day I was like oh actually
you know I fixed my issue but then I
found a whole bunch of other patients
where no one was complaining about it
but we were still doing it so let's
let's all make I'll fix a bunch of those
too and then the maintainer was like oh
great yeah I'm gonna merge it and I was
like you know what when I was in there
like I realized like now I understand
how this all works I'll just go fix this
other issue this issue number four so
then you know now it's been four years
and the number of claw requests I had
merged into that is 171 and you can see
you know that was in December of 2014
even in March of 2015 I was changing
things and all over the module I was
making releases all kinds of stuff like
that so if you stick around there's
probably stuff for you to do all right
so that's the talk I'm going to plug a
couple things at 11:00
thirty which is in nine minutes over on
the far side of the building in Belasco
I will be participating in this panel my
first open source contribution so after
we're done here just head on over there
should be interesting next weekend
Bloomberg is hosting a Python packaging
Authority packaging sprint we're gonna
be working on all kinds of high PA stuff
setup tools virtual amp talks and we're
gonna have mentors and stuff I think at
least on the Saturday the event is sold
out but you should add yourself to the
waitlist and maybe there's still tickets
for Sunday and then finally I want to
thank Bloomberg for like give me the
time to like make this presentation come
to the conference and also all the
support they've given me in doing an
open source outreach and things like
that and also just in general their
support for open source has been great
so if you want to come work at Bloomberg
it's it's it's pretty good alright
that's my talk any questions thanks for
your for your talk can you give me a
sense of when you approach a new package
a new library the first time you're
looking at it how do you start to get a
sense for the internals and the guts of
the project because I think for me
that's maybe the most intimidating part
is sort of where do you start looking to
try and solve your problem yeah so I
mean it's very helpful if you have a
minimal reproducing example or you have
some code that is failing in some way
because one of the good things about
open source is that you can just clone
the repository and then you have all the
code and you know if it's an issue
you're trying to fix up your own or of
someone else's you have an entry point
which is here's something that like
here's some something that's failing and
then hopefully it has a trace back and
the trace box says where in the code is
failing so you set a breakpoint right
before then you know you just modify the
source code make sure that it's in your
path and then you run it and then it'll
stop and then you just like start
exploring it check out the local the
variables at that time like What's in
scope what's not
see what the thing is that's failing
what value does it have maybe what
should have it doesn't always work but
I've often I've often had the same
problem and generally I found that the
biggest issue is getting an entry point
like how do I make it do the same thing
so hopefully like that's one of the
reasons why those issues should happen
while reproducing examples because
otherwise it's just it's really hard to
make the code even hit the part where
you can start looking at these things in
the inner interactive way all right
thanks Paul game
[Applause]